l'ancien président barack obama en
interview la célèbre émission 6t minutes
ce qui est diffusé sur cbs le dimanche
soir alors donald trump aujourd'hui lors
de sa première apparition publique
depuis la semaine dernière ne reconnaît
toujours pas sa défaite il ne concède
rien il attaque toujours la légitimité
de l'élection et les millions de ses
électeurs depuis toujours
ainsi que plusieurs républicains
influents se demande vraiment pourquoi
ils ne lâchent pas prise est toujours de
la tête aux institutions américaines et
à la démocratie mon invité ih amour
qu'on a reçu après au lendemain de cette
élection
il est politologue professeur à l'école
des études internationales avancées à
l'université john hopkins est ce qui
nous a attiré vers lui c'est le peuple
quand la démocratie un ouvrage publié en
2018 où il étudie justement ces régimes
comme ceux que mis en place donald trump
et vous pour ce soir monsieur manque le
soir alors lorsque j'ai parlé l'autre
fois vous nous avez dit quand même la
bonne nouvelle
c'était que régime comme celui du
président trump contrairement à d'autres
pays que vous analysez dans votre
ouvrage c'est qu'il est défait après un
premier mandat
alors là on n'est quand même pas dans la
résignation complète avec ce qui se
passe comment
quel regard portez vous sur la situation
actuelle le fait qu'ils n'ont concept
toujours rien sauf cette petite
déclaration cet après midi où il dit le
temps le dira premièrement les mots les
actions de notre âme pendant ces
derniers jours font de preuves de ce que
moi et beaucoup de collègues deux mois
10 depuis 4 5 ans c'est que les
populistes autoritaires comme d'une
trame son vrai danger pour la démocratie
et qu'ils sont définis tout à fait au
bar dit qu'il croit que jusque sont
légitimes tout le monde qui est pas
d'accord avec eux et illégitime alors du
coup si trempe aurait gagné l'élection
ça aurait été une élection légitime
comme mbaye dème a gagné l'élection elle
peut qu'être illégitime 1me deuxièmement
il ya aussi une bonne nouvelle je veux
quand même là souligné est ce que dans
le train tu n'as pas pris contrôle des
institutions américain jusqu'au point où
il pourrait vraiment
effectué un coup il pourrait vraiment
rester à la maison blanche du coup l'ex
président barack obama a certainement
raison quand il dit que ces événements
sont fondées l'hommage à la démocratie
américaine qui montre qu est-ce que
c'est dans le 30 mai je dois dire que je
n'ai pas vraiment peur qui puisse
empêcher à joe biden de devenir le 36e
président des états unis
mais ce qui aide au fonds c'est aussi le
fait que l'on confirme on verra c'est
certifié vont à semble pas douter qu'il
y a fait des gains en dehors de la
pennsylvanie notamment avec l'arizona le
nevada et la georgie
aujourd'hui et même des équipes de
procureurs qui ont presque honte de
représenter dans notre homme devant les
tribunaux c'est giuliani qui avait lancé
la partie et les gens on se désiste mais
comment expliquez-vous qui encore des
gens influents autour de lui que au
sénat notamment qu'il appuie toujours
les futurs des arômes qui allaient ils
ont peut-être pas beaucoup de
crédibilité vous et des voix fortes
notamment sur fox news et auprès des
sympathisants les 71 millions ou non
voter pour lui
holmes premièrement on voit dans tous
les pays où il ya des dépôts priest
autoritaire qu'il puisse être assez
populaire que c'est pas les tout
derniers que la population va se
détourner contre eux alors du coup moi
je suis personnellement très content que
joe baden y gagner cette élection c'est
assez rare de battre un populiste la
première fois qu'il se repose on au
peuple et ça me surprend pas qu'il y a
quand même pris de 50% de la population
américaine qui le soutient je crois que
beaucoup de membres de son parti souffre
d'une manière de sting drôme de
stockholm et dans le tram les a pris en
otage il y a quatre ans ils ont
peut-être pas être réalisé qu'en fait
ils sont libres maintenant est alors du
coup il continua ses identifié avec
le personnage ce qui leur a pris en
otage c'est quand même très important de
souligner le fait que c'est pas juste
certains avocats qui ont entre
représenter leur train s'est aussi les
juges y compris les jusqu'en donateurs
les juges nommés par des présidents
républicains et qui n'ont pas du tout
est d abord un tram dans cette situation
l'agility série fonctionne encore et ça
c'est un des bonnes nouvelles le solde
est ce que c'est vous qui restent toutes
petites minutes à peine dans votre
ouvrage vous est-elle importante et la
boîte de nuit que nous traversons un
moment populiste se le dise ça va se
transformer à l'époque
est ce que c'est le commencement de la
fin du populisme aux états unis non
parce qu'on n'a pas gagné une victoire
définitive sur le tremplin aux états
unis il ya encore des populistes
gouvernement en inde au brésil en
beaucoup de parts d'europe aussi mais
certainement c'est la première grande
victoire
la première grande bataille qui les
ennemis du populisme en gagner et ça me
rassure quand même que la démocratie
pourra survivre
cette époque pour plus qu à que vous
êtes porteur de bonnes nouvelles chaque
fois qu'on veut pas c'est tout merci je
vous rappelle que vous êtes l'auteur le
peuple contre la démocratie aux éditions
l'observatoire publié en 2010 huit
jeunes et lisez bien tous ces éléments
libres démocratise les démocraties
libérales merci à chamakh à bientôt
j'espère merci à vous d'avoir votre
soirée